ces habitants de Carson cherchent
désespérément de l'électricité et un peu
de chaleur
les frappes russes sont coupées les
accès à l'énergie ce qui met en péril le
fonctionnement des hôpitaux lundi
l'Organisation Mondiale de la Santé a
souligner l'urgence d'anticiper
l'arrivée de l'hiver alors que les
températures en Ukraine risque de
descendre jusqu'à moins 20 degrés
50% de l'infrastructure civile d'énergie
est détruit une menace vitale pour des
millions des Ukrainiens
aussi pour les hôpitaux qui ne peuvent
pas fonctionner sont électriques pas de
maternité ils sont couveuses l'Ukraine a
enregistré 700 attaques contre des
établissements de santé depuis le début
du conflit selon l'OMS qui cherchent à
maintenir les services sanitaires de
base dans le pays c'est important
l'accès aux soins santé sur tout pour
les plus vulnérables par exemple les
gens plus âgés dont des zones récemment
libérées avec des maladies chroniques le
gouvernement ukrainien a commencé à
évacuer des villes récemment libérées
dans les régions de Carson et nicolaïves
de peur que l'hiver et souhaite
invivable
l'OMS évalue entre deux et trois
millions le nombre d'Ukrainiens qui
devraient quitter leur maison à la
recherche de chaleur et de sécurité
covid-19 pneumonie grippe ou diphtérie
les défis sanitaires qui les attendent
sont nombreux
l'OMS a tout de même salué la résilience
du personnel soignant qui permet à
l'Ukraine de maintenir sur pied un
système de santé pourtant à bout de
souffle